[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein nach einem tag mit
wirtschaftspolitischen entwicklungen die
uns alle unmittelbar betreffen zum
ersten mal seit elf jahren hat die
europäische zentralbank die leitzinsen
erhöht dazu gleich mehr dann ist das
heute auch ein tag an dem die deutsche
abhängigkeit von russlands gas und damit
das völlige scheitern der bisherigen
energiepolitik noch mal ganz klar wurde
ein ganzes land tut gezwungenermaßen
exakt das was russlands präsident putin
will es schaut gebannt und mit sorge auf
eine pipeline nord stream 1 verläuft von
der russischen ostseeküste über 1200
kilometer bis nach lubmin in mecklenburg
vorpommern und führt seit heute wieder
gas weniger als möglich wäre zwar aber
immerhin
das ist kein grund für entwarnung sagte
der bundeswirtschaftsminister wir reden
gleich mit ihm sondern zeichen dafür wie
wir erpresst werden ein neuer gas
sparplan soll dagegen halten die details
hat simon pfanzelt
es dürfte im kreml als erfolg gewertet
werden dass sich heute die augen der
deutschen politik auf diese an landes
station im vorpommerschen lubmin richten
wird nach der erwartung wieder gas
fließen zehn tage lang stand diese frage
im raum die antwort lautet ja doch von
entwarnung keine spur der heutige tag
unterstreicht auch wenn jetzt eine
ankündigung da ist dass das gas wieder
fließt dass dieser krieg eben nicht nur
mit waffen gegenüber der ukraine geführt
wird sondern die übrigen kriegsführung
eben bedeutet auch energie
abhängigkeiten als kriegsmittel zu
benutzen abhängigkeit und unsicherheit
es sind die wunden punkte der deutschen
energiepolitik etwa 40 prozent der
maximalen auslastung fließen jetzt
wieder durch nord stream 1 für wie lange
das weiß in berlin niemand dafür seien
die europäer selbst verantwortlich so
sagt es heute putin sprecher der
präsident hat klar gesagt dass gazprom
seine verpflichtungen erfüllt hat
erfüllt und erfüllen wird alle
technischen probleme sind das resultat
europäischer sanktionen die
bundesregierung bezeichnet das als
vorwand und muss sich dennoch auf einen
harten winter
stellen wie die energieversorgung
gesichert werden kann dazu stellt
wirtschaftsminister habeck heute ideen
vor demnach sollen die vorgaben für
mindest füllstände bei gasspeichern
verschärft werden nach der steinkohle
soll ab oktober auch die braunkohle
reaktiviert werden außerdem soll es
wieder mehr home office geben damit
bürokomplexe nicht beheizt werden müssen
wir brauchen einen langen atem
der winter der kommt erst noch und es
ist der erste winter dann braucht der
zweite winter wird nach 1 nach wir
rechnen dieses land und europa noch vor
herausforderungen stellen energie sparen
und energie alternativen ausbauen das
will die bundesregierung putin
entgegensetzen die opposition ist damit
weitestgehend einverstanden doch sie
fordert mehr konkretes und mehr tempo
wir haben jetzt über fünf monate diesen
krieg und jetzt kommen sie so langsam
mal mit vorschlägen wie man eine gas
notlage oder mangel lage lösen könnte
reichlich spät wenn es denn aber hilft
will ich mir gerne konstruktiv anschauen
das nicht mehr wichtig ist ob im
vorpommerschen lubmin gas ankommt oder
nicht das ist das ziel der deutschen
energiepolitik der deutschen
russlandpolitik die abhängigkeit beenden
es ist noch ein weiter weg
und warum läuft das gas auch nach ende
der wartung nur zu 40 prozent der
kapazität durch die pipeline
russland sagt es liegt an einer turbine
von siemens energy die jetzt ins zentrum
eines wirtschafts und polit krimis gerät
so lange sie wegen der sanktionen nicht
repariert zurück nach russland komme
ginge es nicht mehr gas zu liefern
behauptet wladimir putin und so kann man
sich diese turbine ungefähr vorstellen
in bauweise und dimension so lang wie
ein stadtbus zwölf meter fünfzig und
dabei noch vergleichsweise kompakt und
flexibel da sie ursprünglich aus einem
flugzeugtriebwerk entwickelt wurde
normalerweise ist das bauteil wichtig um
den druck in einer pipeline zu erhöhen
jetzt erhöht es auch den politischen
druck robert habeck ist der
bundeswirtschaftsminister
aktuell noch in corona quarantäne
deshalb per videolink heute bei uns
guten amt habe guten abend grüßen ihre
kolleginnen die bundes außenministerin
hat gesagt ohne diese turbine bekommen
wir kein gas mehr dann können wir als
deutschland überhaupt keine
unterstützung mehr für die ukraine
leisten weil wir dann mit
volksaufständen beschäftigt sind das ist
ja in drastischen vielleicht auch
überspitzten worten im grunde das was
putin hören will ist das wirklich so
die kabine ist ein vorgeschobenes
argument ist es ein fadenscheiniges
spiel weil die gazprom gesellschaft
genug termin hat es ist das system ist
so aufgebaut eine wird immer ausgebaut
und eine ist immer als reserve dar dh
diese termine die in kanada regulär zur
wartung war wird nicht gebraucht schon
vor der wartung vom noch zum 1 die
leitung voll auf 100% gefahren werden
können sollte sie aber nicht wir sollten
nicht den fehler machen putin spiel zu
spielen und zu glauben dass er
technische probleme ausgemacht hat das
ist nicht wahr und wir haben ja heute
gesehen das gas kommt wenn auch nicht
und dann wenn wir die leitung liefern
kann aber wenn es nicht an der turbine
liegt
wie kann man dann sagen dass in
deutschland volksaufstände ausbrechen
könnten so wie es annalena baerbock
gemacht hat
wir sind hier ganz gut durch diese zeit
durch gekommen ich finde sogar so dass
wir darauf sehr stolz sein können klar
die preise sind immer hoch wir haben
sehr hohe inflation wir haben eine eine
angespannte lage in deutschland was die
energiepreise und auch die energie
versorgung angeht user patient nicht
hatten aber die menschen stehen der
zusammen und auch der politische diskurs
ist wenn man von den üblichen debatten
und die unterscheiden uns ja vergrößert
die brauchen wir ja einmal absieht doch
einer der auflösung ausgerichtet ist und
diese lösung die brauchen wir sind ein
starkes land mit einem starken
zusammenspiel zwischen den menschen
zwischen der wirtschaft und der
zivilgesellschaft und der politik habe
und das wird schon noch erleben wie
stark wir sind aber haben sie auch so
wie ihre kolleginnen im auswärtigen amt
angst dass sich das ändern könnte und
zwar dramatisch
ich weiß dass putin darauf ziel ist zu
ändern dass die preise hoch gehalten
werden künstlich hoch gehalten werden
soll natürlich genau anders kurs
vorbereiten wo man
missgünstig wird wo man schuldige
gesucht wo man also nicht standortsuche
das ist natürlich völlig klar hier
verantwortung hat nämlich die
bundesregierung auch meine person aber
wo man versucht die gemeinsamkeit und
dann aber auch die gemeinsamkeiten mit
der ukraine näher auseinander zu treiben
und es gibt ja erste erfolge auf dem
rechten und manchmal auch auf dem linken
hand wird genau dieser diskurs jetzt
schon belegt aber es sind irgendwo die
wir sollten sie aufpassen das ist nur
hände bleiben okay ich hatte mal fest
sie schließen sich den worten der
bundeskanzlerin also nicht an heute
abend habe der schlimmste fall ist ja
jetzt heute erstmal nicht eingetreten
das wird jetzt weiter gas geliefert sie
haben gerade gesagt wie hoch ist denn
die gefahr dass jetzt alle sagen prima
dann können wir uns ja weiter durch
vorstellen ich glaube nichts nicht so
sehr hoch aber eine gefahr wäre ist weil
wir ja sehen das tut ihnen dies die
verfügbarkeit des gases mehr wieder
strategisch einsetzt und wie eben kurz
jedenfalls andiskutiert strategisch
einsetzen um die entschlossenheit und
auch die geschlossenheit in europa und
in deutschland zu spalten insofern
sollten wir uns dann nicht mehr
bewegen und mich aufstellen das wird
immer wieder weiter gehen immer wieder
werden technische gründe vorgeschoben
werden immer wieder wird irgendwas
passieren um die gasmenge zu verknappen
sie kann auch mal wieder steigen um
genau den effekt auszulösen wenn sie
beschrieben haben eine art 8 oder
sorglosigkeit richtige antwort ist wir
müssen akzeptieren dass putin diesen
gashebel gegen uns einsetzt wir müssen
uns alternativen besorgen wir besorgen
uns alternativen der müssen sparsam sein
und verbräuche runter bekommen und dann
kommt ja auch gut durch diesen winter
alternativen ist das stichwort wir sehen
wie erpressbar wir sind und
interessanterweise fordert auch niemand
mehr ganz raus zu gehen aus nord stream
1 also aus den gaslieferungen aus
russland das war ja noch vor ein paar
monaten ganz anders was sagen sie denn
denen die jetzt sogar mit dem gedanken
spielen nord stream zwei möglicherweise
doch ans netz zu lassen
also ich habe ja damals schon und damals
gab es doch eigentlich mehrheit der
bevölkerung für die sofortige
sanktionierung von russischem gas gesagt
das ist eine falsche forderung und man
kann in dieser zeit nicht politik macht
umfragen machen sondern nur lars
erkenntnissen und zu den erkenntnissen
gehört auch dass wir nicht die
abhängigkeit von russischen gas noch
erhöhen dürften trotzdem zwei ist nicht
genehmigt ist unterliegt den
amerikanischen sanktionen wenn noch zwei
also die zweite teil bleibe jetzt
aufgemacht wird würde sich doch
überhaupt nichts ändern außer dass wir
noch abhängiger von russischem gas
wieder werden würden und putin dann auch
sein ziel gegen deutschland in europa
erreichte nämlich dieser aktion zu
brechen was das wäre das hissen der
weißen fahne
das sollten wir auf keinen fall tun in
deutschland ist es sehr wichtig dass die
eu staaten sich gegenseitig unterstützen
gerade für deutschland ist das aktuell
sehr wichtig und da auch solidarität
zeigen jetzt hört man aus vielen teilen
der eu dass sie das nicht machen wollen
die polen haben gesagt sie würden ihr
gas ungern nur mit deutschland teilen
kritik an an ideen der eu-kommission
kommt auch aus spanien aus portugal aus
griechenland man hat den eindruck jeder
ist sich selbst der nächste geht er
jetzt ein hauen und stechen um das gas
in europa los das wäre schlimm wenn zu
mir weil wir keine daten gewisser sind
natürlich gilt das für das stars in
deutschland ist ein transitland wir
versorgen
welche in österreich mit sind ja wenn
klopp kann schließt also länder die
keinen zugang haben sie brauchen zugang
zu anderen ländern die sie die sie
versorgen auch die ukraine bekannt von
deutschland mit versorgt werden und
würde auch mitversorgt werden schon
morgen wieder ein so genannten reverse
stock split die richtung um aber
umgekehrt ist natürlich auch angewiesen
auf die solidarität der anderen länder
wenn die niederländer geht er ja ihre
terminals nicht nutzen würden uns gas zu
geben dann würden wir ganz schön dumm
gucken aber was soll denn da habe ich
was sagen sie denn zu den polen was in
spanien und in portugal ich sagen das
ist uns egal wir haben unsere eigenen
probleme dass sie verkennen die verbogen
der kontinent ist und sollte ist eine
wirtschaftskrise in deutschland geben
würde doch portugal oder spanien um das
recht nicht polen oder frankreich davon
unberührt bleiben wir können in
deutschland in europa nicht mehr
nationalen denken die interessen sind so
verschreckt miteinander dass wir nur
dann stark sind denn wir gemeinsam und
solidarisch agieren und natürlich gilt
das ja auch für deutschland in anderen
phasen sind wir diejenigen die geben
also geld oder wirtschaftskraft oder
unterstützung und die anderen länder
auch zu recht sagen ihr seid ein starkes
wirtschaftsland im zentrum ist uns ein
helfen bei den aufbau über den
ländlichen räumen das wollen wir auch
gerne tun jetzt brauchen wir eine
solidarität des kontinents insgesamt
nicht nur für deutschland die anderen
länder die ich bin ein paar gebrauchen
die ja auch und darüber wird dann am
dienstag im rat in brüssel gesprochen
werden ich bin noch die hoffnung dass
der starken gedanke sich gegenseitig zu
helfen europa weiter prägen sind sagt
der bundeswirtschaftsminister robert
habeck herberg vielen dank für das
gespräch und gut an gering
und das gespräch haben wir aus
termingründen heute abend aufgezeichnet
später im heute-journal update fragen an
die oppositionsführerin in belarus es
wird ja atlanta die hawks kaya sie
kritisiert deutschlands fortgesetztes
gasgeschäft mit russland und sagt es
sollte keine deals zwischen demokratien
und diktatoren geben
die zinsen steigen dass kein sparer
freuen das sorgt bei vielen die kredite
abzahlen für große probleme und zwar
sowohl bei denen die sich in
vergleichsweise kleinem rahmen zum
beispiel geld für ein haus geliehen
haben als auch bei denen die in nicht
mehr wirklich fassbar im umfang gleich
den gesamten staat verschuldet haben
italien war heute in europas zentralbank
ein wichtiger faktor bei der
entscheidung zumal das land gerade in
einer neuen regierungskrise steckt und
so fällt die zinsanhebung mit 0,5
prozentpunkten zwar höher aus als
erwartet
sie kommt aber daher mit einem neuen
notfall programm für extrem verschuldete
euro länder das wieder fragen aufwirft
stefan schlosser
jetzt haben sie getan was notenbanker
eigentlich nie tun überraschen als
christine lagarde vor die presse tritt
ist bereits klar dass ein erster
zinsschritt kommen wird mit leichten 0,5
prozent fällt dieser aber unerwartet
deutlich aus
ich zb rat gelangte zu der einschätzung
dass im zuge seiner leitzins
normalisierung ein größerer erster
schritt angemessen ist als auf seiner
letzten sitzung signalisiert
dieser beschluss basiert auf unserer
aktualisierten beurteilung der
inflationsrisiken zu
zögerlich zu spät die kritik an der ezb
bei laut und deutlich angesichts hoher
inflationsraten von über 8 prozent im
euroraum jetzt hat die nullzinspolitik
ein ende profitieren können sparer
banken müssen keine strafzinsen mehr
zahlen wenn sie ihr geld bei der
zentralbank parken
die gebühren sollten dann auch für
bankkunden wegfallen und höhere zinsen
aufs ersparte sind auch wieder drin
langsam wird der sparer auch wieder
etwas mehr zins auf sein konto bekommen
aber nicht vergessen solange die
inflation natürlich so extrem hoch
bleibt verliert der sparer auch bei dem
jetzigen zinsniveau weiterhin geld
auswirkungen der zinswende hat der
immobilienmarkt in teilen schon
vorweggenommen die bauzinsen haben sich
in den vergangenen monaten vervielfacht
max herbst ist finanzberater seit über
30 jahren im geschäft so eine
entwicklung hat er noch nicht erlebt
eine beispielrechnung zeigt den
dramatischen anstieg
wenn man darin
1021 eine rate von knapp 9 wurde dieses
jahr 1575 euro was einer differenz von
693 euro ausmacht verdoppelung berater
für viele die zu niedrigen zinsen
finanziert haben und demnächst zu
deutlich höheren zinsen eine
anschlussfinanzierung brauchen könnte
der traum vom haus platzen es gibt immer
noch ganze menge leute gehört die nur 1
prozent vielleicht 15 prozent leisten
konnten sie nicht mehr leisten konnten
von der mutter brachte und diese leute
oft auch sehr wenig eigenkapital und
genau diese gruppe kann wird sehr
wahrscheinlich mit den hohen zinsen
probleme kriegen wenn die
anschlussfinanzierung ansteht höhere
zinsen belasten nicht nur
immobilienkäufer auch starten sind
betroffen beispiel italien das gerade in
einer regierungskrise steckt
schuldenmachen wird künftig teurer
werden die ezb stellte heute ein neues
geldpolitisches instrument vor so dass
schwächere länder auch weiterhin billig
an frisches geld kommen können das
könnte aber neue probleme schaffen
wenn eine zentralbank staatsanleihen
kauft dann muss sie diese staatsanleihen
jemanden abkaufen und ihm dafür geld
geben und im regelfall gelangt dadurch
neues frisches geld in umlauf was am
ende natürlich eine inflationsgefahr
darstellt und sie begibt sich rechtlich
auf dünnes eis wenn sie einzelnen
staaten gezielt hilft stichwort
staatsfinanzierung
ja dünnes eis das sollten uns noch mal
genauer anschauen die eurozone erlebt ja
gerade viel unsicherheit jetzt kommt
noch dazu dass ein garant für stabilität
in italien ausfällt der bisherige
ministerpräsident mario draghi auch bei
der ezb ja kein unbekannter ist
zurückgetreten das land trudelt richtung
neuwahlen in dieser situation schafft
die ezb also ein neues instrument das
speziell den schuldenstaaten aus der
patsche helfen soll frank bethmann guten
abend wie kommt denn dieses neue
instrument an ja es ist hochumstritten
nicht zuletzt wegen dieser aktuellen
regierungskrise in italien die eben
tatsächlich sofort zeigt wie schmal der
grat wirklich ist heute vorgestellt ist
das instrument namens cpi gleich auf dem
prüfstand denn bereits heute stiegen die
renditen italienischer anleihen noch mal
deutlich an risikoaufschläge
eigentlich also grund genug für die ezb
einzugreifen italienische staatsanleihen
zu kaufen damit die rendite wieder sinkt
der druck abnimmt ausgerechnet eine
regierungskrise jedoch gilt als
musterbeispiel dafür
tp ein nicht einzusetzen nur bei
spekulativen angriffen auf ein land soll
die notenbank nach eigenen vorgaben
tätig werden nicht bei hausgemachten
problemen über sie jetzt hier in italien
gerade erleben doch mit dieser aufgabe
beide sauber von kinder zu trennen
hausgemacht oder doch spekulativ gerät
die ezb das musste selbst
bundesbank-präsident joachim nagel zu
geben in ganz gefährliches fahrwasser
das klar zu trennen sei fast unmöglich
einiges noch zu klären herzlichen dank
frank wiesmann in frankfurt und jetzt
die nachrichten in der übersicht heute
die hat johanna und wir beginnen mit
einer meldung direkt auf dem weißen haus
denn dort befindet sich der us-präsident
seit heute in isolation joe biden hat
sich mit dem corona virus infiziert der
79-jährige habe sehr milde symptome und
werde mit dem medikament pack slow food
behandelt er arbeite weiter per telefon
und videokonferenzen
die steuereinnahmen von bund und ländern
sind im ersten halbjahr
2022 deutlich gestiegen das plus betrug
im vergleich zum vorjahreszeitraum 17,5
prozent die einnahmen lagen bei 408
milliarden euro grund für den kräftigen
anstieg ist laut bundesfinanzministerium
auch die korona pandemie denn deren
auswirkungen und die steuerlichen
maßnahmen zur abfederung hatten das
steueraufkommen im vergangenen jahr
gemindert
der vatikan hat sich in einer erklärung
kritisch zum synodalen weg in
deutschland geäußert so heißt das zu den
reformbestrebungen der synodale weg sei
nicht befugt bischöfe und gläubige zur
annahme neuer formen der leitung und
neuer ausrichtungen der lehre und der
moral zu verpflichten als grund nennt
der vatikan eine mögliche bedrohung der
einheit der katholischen kirche der
synode weg ist ein gesprächsformat von
laien und bischöfen dabei geht es um
reformen wie das mitspracherecht von
gläubigen bei der ernennung von
bischöfen um die position der frauen
oder das zölibat
seit wochen protestieren in sri lanka
viele menschen gegen die politische
führung nun hat das von einer schweren
wirtschaftskrise gebeutelte land einen
neuen präsidenten ranil wickremesinghe
wird nachfolger von gotabaya rajapakse
der außer landes geflohen ist der 73
jährige war bisher ministerpräsident
den protestierenden ist der unbeliebt
weil er als verbündeter seines
vorgängers gilt
das menschenrechtsbüro der osze erhebt
schwere vorwürfe gegen russland in einem
bericht werden schwerwiegende und
massenhaften verstöße gegen das
humanitäre völkerrecht seit beginn des
krieges gegen die ukraine dokumentiert
besonders gravierende fälle seien der
beschuss des theaters voller flüchtlinge
in mario pohl mitte märz und des
belebten bahnhofs von kramer tosca
anfang april auch auf ukrainischer seite
soll es verstöße gegeben haben etwa
durch gewalt gegen mutmaßliche plünderer
unsere reporterin julia held nimmt uns
jetzt mit in ein kleines dorf etwa 140
kilometer entfernt von kiew und in die
abgründe dessen was menschen in der lage
sind anderen menschen an zu tun was in
ja hätte ne geschah ist mit normalem
verstand nicht zu begreifen vier wochen
lang war das ganze dorf in der hand
russische soldaten die alle an einwohner
in einen keller sperrten männer frauen
kinder die älteste geisel war 93 die
jüngste ein baby von eineinhalb monaten
sie mussten hungern sie hatten
furchtbare angst einige wurden
erschossen jetzt versucht er hätte einen
weg zu finden um all das zu verarbeiten
und dabei angst dass russlands armee
zurück kommt
es sind 15 treppenstufen nur aber sie
führen weil er ab juli mitten zurück in
einen albtraum den er wohl nie vergessen
wird
boris drauf mutter muss es war
schrecklich weil wir morgens nie wussten
ob wir bis zum abend über leben und am
abend nicht ob es bis zum nächsten
morgen schaffen es gab nicht genügend
sauerstoff vor allem von den alten sind
viele verrückt geworden und gestorben
das budget castro doris hummer rose
apotheke
einen monat lang waren sie hier unten
eingesperrt in diesem keller einer
schule
360 menschen zusammengepfercht ein
ganzes dorf in geiselhaft
wirklich nur die kranken und alten
konten liegen alle anderen mussten
sitzen sie brauchen ist
tot hier saß ich hier meine zwei kinder
dort meine frau und meine eltern so
saßen wir 28 tage lang trotz new jersey
die feuchte luft kaum sauerstoff kaum
essen ein eimer als toilette schnell
hätten sich krankheiten ausgebreitet
erzählt weil lehrer paul louis und zeigt
uns wie sie versucht hätten in diesem
horror trotzdem einen überblick zu
behalten
da müssen wir haben wir geschrieben wer
hier im raum gestorben ist und hier wer
im dorf erschossen wurde
insgesamt 26 menschen seien in diesen
wochen gestorben an den bedingungen im
keller oder weil sie von den russischen
besatzern erschossen wurden weil lehrer
nimmt uns mit auf den friedhof wo sie
ihre toten begraben durften immer dann
wenn es im keller zu viele wurden nur
ein paar minuten zeit hätten ihnen die
soldaten dafür gegeben
sie haben ständig wiederholt wie
schlecht die erde bei ihnen zu hause im
ural sei voller steine und wie locker
dagegen unsere erde da wäre es doch gar
kein problem schnell zu graben
vier monate liegt all das inzwischen
zurück für die menschen im ort aber gibt
es nach wie vor kein anderes thema ein
ganzes dorf gefangen im gleichen trauma
und das liegt aber es sind erst aus dem
ausland gekommen und psychologen um uns
zu helfen aber wir alle erinnern uns bei
jedem schritt und tritt daran was
passiert ist und wir haben alle angst
dass die russen zurückkommen
sie versuchen zurück zur normalität zu
finden in jahr hätten zumindest die
sichtbaren spuren des horrors zu
beseitigen
hilfsorganisationen sind gekommen um
beim wiederaufbau zu helfen
die seelischen wunden aber das wissen
sie alle hier im dorf werden wohl lange
nicht teilen
jetzt machen wir einen schnitt in der
sendung die sendung muss auch an so
einer stelle weiter gehen und machen
weiter mit diana bei der lufthansa droht
ein streik der piloten und das eventuell
noch in der ferienzeit die gewerkschaft
cockpit hat heute mit einer urabstimmung
dazu begonnen die bis ende des monats
laufen soll hintergrund sind die
festgefahrenen
verhandlungen über einen neuen
gehaltstarifvertrag
die gewerkschaft fordert von der
lufthansa unter anderem fünf prozent
mehr lohn bei der tour de france hat der
träger des gelben trikots jonas winkel
bord die als besonders anspruchsvoll
geltende acht zehnte etappe für sich
entschieden und sich in der
gesamtwertung einen kaum noch
einzuholenden vorsprung gesichert der
däne holte am vorletzten tag der tour de
france außerdem die entscheidenden
punkte in der bergwertung und die
starboot simon geschke traum vom berg
trikot endgültig platzen und
jetzt zur fußball wm der frauen und zu
einem ergebnis das auch der heute
verstorbenen fußball legende uwe seeler
ohne frage gefallen hätte die deutsche
nationalelf steht nach dem spiel gegen
österreich im halbfinale der
europameisterschaft der jubel war groß
aber vor spielbeginn wurde erst mal an
einen ganz großen erinnert er hatte das
spiel heute eigentlich gucken wollen so
eine tief bewegte bundes trainerin voss
tecklenburg vor dem anpfiff
schweigeminute zu ehren von uwe seeler
die österreicherinnen mit dem besseren
start marina georg hier war der
außenpfosten bewahrt das deutsche team
vor einem rückstand 25 minute fehler
österreich im spielaufbau klara buhl
setzt gut nach und lina magull mit dem 1
0 die zweite halbzeit ein wahres
aluminium spektakel erst deutschland mit
julia gewinnen dann zweimal die immer
stärker werdenden österreicherinnen
und es knallt weiter im londoner
stadtteil brent ford klara buhl 78
minute spannung bis in die
schlussminuten bis zu diesem fauxpas der
österreichischen torfrau alexandra popp
staubt ab das 2 0 der endstand
deutschland trifft nun im halbfinale auf
frankreich oder die niederlande
und uwe das ist ein ehrentitel den kein
bundespräsident verleihen kann den es
nicht zu kaufen gibt man kann ihn sich
auch nicht wünschen uwe seeler war schon
zu lebzeiten ein wahrzeichen seiner
heimatstadt hamburg treu bescheiden
bodenständig nie hat der legendäre
mittelstürmer seinen hsv verlassen auch
für ein vielfaches an geld nicht uns uwe
hält anlässlich des todes von uwe seeler
ändert das zdf sein programm und zeigt
gleich nach uns einen ausführlichen
nachruf zusammen 85 geburtstag im
november hatte deutschlands erster
fußballer des jahres zurück geschaut und
gesagt ich glaube ich habe so weit alles
richtig gemacht ich bin zufrieden
das war unsere welt an diesem
donnerstagmorgen freut sich hier mein
kollege wulf schmiese auf sie wir sehen
uns nach dem wochenende wieder am montag
[Musik]
guten abend wie außergewöhnlich 40 grad
bei uns in deutschland sind zeigt diese
grafik seit beginn regelmäßiger
wetteraufzeichnungen
1880 gab es nur zehn solcher tage und
bis 1983 überhaupt gar kein 2003 waren
es drei 2015 2 2009 10 3 und 2022 einer
gestern eben jetzt ist die hitze erst
mal abgeräumt das liegt an dem tief
caroline das brachte ja regenschauer und
gewitter mit und jetzt wird es erst mal
ruhig bei uns aber in der nacht zu
samstag kommen dann von westen schon
wieder neue schauer und gewitter heran
heute nacht regnet es noch etwas hier im
nordwesten mit dem tief caroline sonst
ist es häufig klar und die
nachttemperaturen werden wieder etwas
erträglicher 18 grad sind es in der
uckermark 12 grad am alpenrand
am morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen
an der see bei 17 bis 21 grad sonst sind
es im norden so etwa 23 bis 30 im süden
30 bis 34 grad im norden gibt es morgen
mehr wolken im süden mehr sonne bei
westwind und in der nacht zu samstag und
samstag über tag ziehen dann
regenschauer und gewitter von west nach
ost über uns hinweg der sonntag wird
sonnig und der montag heiß wie sie aber
hier am trend für leipzig sehen können
ist das ganze nur ein one day wonder das
heißt danach geht es wieder deutlich
gedämpfter weiter mit der hitze guten
abend